let me go next to our caller from the
7:01 area code who's calling today from
701 hi David hey who's this I'm this is
Chris my question is do you think Joe
Biden is betting everything on South
Carolina and how much will that actually
matter to him in the race
well incredibly there's a recent poll
out of South Carolina where Biden is
only up five I mean Biden early was
expected to crush at South Carolina win
by 20 or 25 points one poll recently
says he's only up five so his advisors
did say he doesn't need to win Iowa or
New Hampshire because he's gonna do well
in Nevada and South Carolina and there's
more delegates there that may be true
except in Nevada now he is almost in a
virtual statistical tie and in South
Carolina he's not doing really as well
as he was here's the problem for Joe
Biden how does he justify continuing to
raise money right if you are a centrist
Democrat you want to see someone like
Biden Budaj edge globish are or
Bloomberg win how do you justify
donating to Biden when he did so poorly
in Iowa you might say I'm gonna donate
to Pete or you might say I'm just gonna
stop donating and hope Bloomberg takes
over because he doesn't even need my
money he's got hundreds of millions that
he's already spent so for me the problem
with Biden is less about the results in
these first few elections it's more
about how does he keep raising money how
does he justify saying hey give me your
money because he is not the exciting
candidate it's basically saying hey I'm
a known entity and I'm the statesman and
I have experience and he lost in Iowa so
that's the real concern for Biden I
think that that makes perfect sense
can I just add that last caller yeah the
reason that there are there is no
establishment Democrats in Wyoming is
because they're all Republicans and they
want to be elected that's that's an
interesting point yeah if you're a
progressive then you're a Democrat but
if you're even remotely centrist you
realize that the way to win is to be a
Republican in that state love the fill
thanks David all right thank you for the
call appreciate it Chris